e o Instituto de Pesquisa chamado Inep
desenvolver um estudo que nos mostra que
somente 25 porcento dos Pais brasileiros
acompanham os estudos das suas crianças
em casa Em contrapartida 65 por cento
dos Pais nos países mais ricos fazem
esse acompanhamento ou seja tem aí uma
grande diferença que tem uma
representação importante a sobre isso eu
sou Educadora bastante tempo e tenho
feito roda de conversa com pais roda de
conversa com educadores e eu quero saber
que tem uma coisa muito simples que pode
trazer muito resultado e que pode fazer
muita diferença
coisa simples a essa que nós podemos
fazer se pode trazer essa diferença essa
coisa assim é a lição de casa é estar
presente durante a lição de casa dos
filhos
e este momento de convívio da lição de
casa é um momento importante Onde se
cria vínculos onde se fortalece vínculos
é um momento de aproximação é um momento
de colaboração é um momento de
participação É nesse momento da lição de
casa que nós podemos ter ser a nossa
rede de confiança a nossa rede de apoio
familiar e é através desse convivo
importante da lição de casa que as
crianças podem se sentir seguras para
responder aos desafios escolares que
elas têm pela frente os pais por sua vez
também ficam bastante inseguro de qual é
o seu papel na lição de casa eles têm
que responder todas as dúvidas das
matérias escolares até que ponto eles
têm que ajudar bem nós não estamos
esperando que os pais atua em como
professores cada um tem que fazer sua
parte os professores fazem sua parte na
escola e os pais e aqui em casa o que
realmente a importante durante a se
momento da lição de casa está presente é
atenção eu respeito é mostrar como você
valoriza o trabalho que seu filho
desenvolve é a proximidade o grande.
Focal desse trabalho é a convivência são
os vínculos
Rubem Alves Diz presente que o que
realmente é importante ser apreendido na
vida nada tem a ver com informação o que
realmente ensina é a relação lúdica
entre pais e filhos é este vínculo
afetivo que se forma entre pais e filhos
nós damos muita importância para
tecnologia nós damos muita importância
para os métodos e para as técnicas nós
damos muita importância para ciências
mas nós esquecemos o quão necessário e
importante é é o livro familiar que cria
apoio que cria sustentação que cria
confiança
bem nós não podemos esperar que a
tecnologia resolva tudo e nós também não
podemos esperar que a escola seja a
única responsável por todo esse processo
então o que que nós temos que fazer
educação Como eu disse é um processo
conjunto entre a família e entre a
escola então vamos fazer a nossa parte
nós queremos mudar o mundo sem queremos
Então vamos assumir a nossa
responsabilidade sobre isso está
presente durante a lição de casa é uma
grande possibilidade de fazer a
diferença na criação dos nossos filhos
na preparação dos nossos filhos no
desenvolvimento dos nossos filhos para
que eles sim possam criar o mundo melhor